this is Startalk let's check out what
jared has to ask and Jerry Jarrett just
goes with Jared man he's like Cher and
Madonna and Madonna okay right you know
it's just Jared okay
Jared says both Madonna's had only one
name which one is more famous by the way
that's a good question so here's what
yard says hey Neil quick question
I love his conversational tone oh nice
hey Neil quick question as I am sure you
get do I have a quick answer see that's
what it really comes down to and then
we're going I'm sure you get tons of
questions but with the recent claim that
the Higgs had been discovered over 99%
not quite 100% a thought occurred to me
if the Higgs gives mass to objects and
the universe is normally symmetrical ie
matter antimatter is there an anti Higgs
if yes could ear a theoretical anti
hitch generator reduce mass enough to
allow faster than light travel ah man
this dude thinks he is the chief
engineer on the Starship Enterprise
thinking and depending on his age he's
one of these kinds that I wonder what
he's building in his basement oh I know
what he's smoking in this basement I
don't know what he's built in his
basement
but I know what he smoked before he
tried to build it all right so basically
let's talk about this anti hits
antimatter could this happen yes so the
Higgs particle is what's called a boson
and and there are some particle physics
classes that I never took and so some of
what I'd know there I learned
osmotically from particle physics
colleagues of mine the rest I learned
formally so I may be stepping across
that edge right now okay but Higgs being
a boson boson is a class of particle
that does not itself have an anti
particle okay like a photon light is a
boson there's no anti photon right all
right so so what you're so the the
premise here would be that same boson
would be granting mass to an anti
particle just as it would be granting
mass to
gotcha that's my answer and if I'm wrong
one of my physics colleagues will write
I'll tell ya there yeah yeah but I
that's so this because of the class of
particle that it is right so he so so
whatever's going on in his basement he
has to make it has to modify his plans
yes and please stop it whatever you're
doing in your basement please okay we
don't want to go